bustling busy Brixton in South London it
looks normal enough
but then again masks help hide the doubt
large swathes of Britain are preparing
for release within days but amid all the
anticipation
a new poll for Sky News revealed the
public braced and willing to accept a
second lockdown in the event of another
coronavirus spike we found 83% saying
they'd support a second lockdown while
only 9% told our pollsters you garb they
would oppose it but accepting it doesn't
mean relishing it come the autumn it's
very important to be around your family
leading up to Christmas and I think
that'd be really hard for me but then
you know if that's if that's what the
science needs then yeah I'd obviously
support it and try and stick to it as I
can I supported a lot done because I
think we are part of a community and we
have to help each other this is the way
to do that we can't just run away from
it I'm very happy to stay at home and
lock down again this part of South
London had one of the lowest number of
Kovach 19 cases and with the entire
hospitality sector on the brink the days
ahead are likely to be critical this pub
landlord nervous but looking forward to
the weekend we're fully booked on
Saturday as in for the numbers that we
want to have in safely and that's to
allow people to walk in so for us it
seems that everybody wants that Saturday
as their first point looking for two
welcome welcoming back all the regulars
but it seems the public at this moment
are less ready 70 percent told you guv
they were uncomfortable about going back
into pubs in the next week or two while
60 percent said they felt uncomfortable
at the prospect of eating a meal in a
restaurant pubs that need free booking
virtual queuing and hosts that make sure
you don't get too tipsy to ensure that
you obey social distancing rules now the
headlines have called it Super Saturday
but our survey reveals that in truth the
British public are picked away back to
normality
I don't mind maybe going to a friend's
house and say I'm having a few drinks
with her but going to the pubs and going
to open spaces with loads of people that
is a bit risky and I don't I don't feel
that comfortable doing that
similarly 70% of the public said that
they were uncomfortable returning to
cinemas 60% reluctant to return to
shopping centres yet when it comes to
going back to visiting people in their
home things change 62% are comfortable
going to see friends or family at home
compared to just 34% who aren't there
will be a concern amongst the
government's that many people still
don't feel comfortable
returning to MIT some of those venues
that are reopening this weekend
particularly pubs restaurants bars and
that might mean that the quick economic
recovery that some of them are hoping
for maybe a little bit slower the doors
are unlocked but people don't have to go
out how will they vote with their feet
from this weekend
Sam Koch sky needs